now someone who's fundraising has been
supercharged over the last couple of
weeks is Donald Trump Donald Trump's
campaign grifting I'm sorry sorry
fundraising has really been supercharged
by his arrest although I don't think
that tells us anything about what this
does for him in a potential general
election matchup and my opinion is that
the arrest is very bad for Trump
Politico is reporting indictment turbo
charges Trump's fundraising the former
president's two political entities
brought in 18.8 million during the first
quarter of this year now of course that
predates the arrest but the article
reads Trump raised the combined 18.8
million in the first quarter but the
campaign says and again remember
until they make the FEC filing the fact
that they say they've raised this much
money is it has not been proven but
let's give them the benefit of the doubt
even though they lie all the time and
say we believe them they say that they
were able to raise
15.4 million dollars in just two weeks
after charges were filed against Trump
which is a suggestion that Trump is
growing as fundraising base and it says
nearly a quarter of those who
contributed to Trump during that
two-week period after the arrest had
never given to Trump before
I remain convinced that the arrest is
good for Trump in the primary and not
good for Trump in the general election I
believe and it seems clear from the data
from the claims we'll get the data at
the end of the quarter but it seems
clear that when you see wow accelerated
fundraising for Trump after the arrest
and also a quarter of the donors never
donated to Trump before it certainly is
feasible to believe from that
that there are existing Republicans and
likely
Trump supporters who just never donated
before maybe because they couldn't
afford to maybe because they can't
really afford to now and still shouldn't
be no donating to Trump who after all is
a billionaire why does Trump need to
fundraise if he's a billionaire and the
whole thing was I don't need anybody's
money I can finance my own campaign okay
put that aside
I don't doubt that the counter narrative
and the propaganda that Trump and others
are spreading about the arrest is
helping Trump raise money from Maga
types and I don't doubt that this may
even help Trump's polling which we will
be looking at on tomorrow's program in
the primary but as far as the general
election goes if Trump is indeed the
nominee I don't think this gets him a
single additional vote I don't see any
way that it does the folks who are
actually connected to reality and look
at things in a sane and sober way are
overwhelmingly going to see Trump as a
chaotic and beleaguered candidate
because of the arrest so I'm with many
on the right who have been saying this
seals Trump's primary Victory I don't
disagree that that's an accurate
interpretation of what is going on
I don't think this is good for Trump in
the general and of course I'm making a
prediction and we will have to wait and
see